this is cairo
egypt's largest city and its capital
for decades it's been home to egyptian
rulers and their palaces the parliament
has met in this building for over 150
years and this public square in the
heart of cairo has been the site of
several revolutions
but in 2015 the egyptian government
announced the capital would move about
50 kilometers away to this patch of
empty desert which is quickly shaping up
to be the new administrative capital of
egypt this is where a new presidential
palace will go the new parliament
building and a new public square
egypt's government led by president
abdel fattah al-sisi claims this new
city will solve a specific problem
cairo's overpopulation
but the country has a long history of
building new cities to decongest cairo
many of them sit outside the city today
so why is cairo's population still
considered a ticking time bomb
[Music]
and what's the real reason behind this
new capital
[Music]
there's a population counter outside one
of the ministries it's mundane but it
also it's red flashing lights with these
colors is almost kind of always like
telling people a little too many of you
are here
this is muhammad al-shahid an
architectural historian who studies
urban development in egypt and i find
this to be quite a a dangerous narrative
especially that
that's actually not the case egypt's
home to more than 100 million people and
about 20 of them live within the
boundaries of greater cairo the city has
one of the highest population densities
in the world with 153 000 people per
square kilometer at its peak that's
higher than new york london and shanghai
what we know as cairo today was
officially founded on the banks of the
nile in the 10th century as the capital
of the arab fatimid caliphate the city
had to be built near the river because
the rest of the region was barren desert
over the next several centuries each
ruler built expansions of cairo close to
the fertile banks the ottomans built
these areas and the british added these
suburbs during their decades-long
occupation of egypt in the 1950s when
the british left and egypt became a
republic cairo was by far the biggest
city
in the 50s 60s and 70s millions of
impoverished egyptians from the
countryside moved to cairo in search of
opportunities and better living
conditions
but the city that was built haphazardly
along the river wasn't equipped to house
more people this city sort of was
already kind of shaped and demarcated
and the green areas around it were left
agricultural and it's those areas that
were cheap and close enough to those
amenities that allowed then people to
step in since the housing that was
available was completely
not sufficient so farmers started
selling small slices of their
agricultural land to the migrants and a
lot of people had to build for
themselves with little money so together
so entire families would grow vertical
on a small plot of land these were the
first informal and technically illegal
neighborhoods it's informal because it's
not um you know given licenses for
construction it's built outside of
uh the economy that is kind of the
official economy and i think this is
actually the result of the fact that the
economic system really excluded the
majority of the population for decades
egypt's government failed to build
affordable housing or invest in public
services and infrastructure to support
the explosive growth in cairo's density
and that meant these unplanned and
informal neighborhoods continued to get
more and more crowded until it became a
crisis egypt's capital is bursting at
the seams cairo is equipped to handle
around three million in fact it's home
to eight million housing is the area of
desperate need many people in cairo
lived in makeshift shacks in the city
center and in much worse conditions in
the suburbs
today these informal neighborhoods are
home to 60 of cairo's population
most of them are inhabited by the poor
but many have evolved into middle class
neighborhoods
collectively these are the most crowded
areas of cairo and egypt's government
under sisi points to them as the real
problem behind cairo's overcrowding i
find this to be a very problematic
narrative because then we take a
question of let's say bad design or bad
management from a state perspective
and turn the blame on actually the
people who are suffering from the bad
design and the bad policies and say
there's just too many of you in fact the
government still considers them illegal
referring to them as slums from the
point of view of the state that calling
an area a slung facilitates its removal
in 2019 the government announced it
would eradicate cairo's slums by 2030.
many neighborhoods will be redeveloped
as affluent housing while thousands of
residents will be forcibly pushed out of
their homes and into affordable housing
outside the city
but instead of focusing on sufficient
affordable housing they invested
billions of dollars in a whole new city
elsewhere
and it's not the first time an egyptian
ruler has tried to solve the crisis by
starting fresh in the desert
a building boom is in progress
new apartment blocks have been going up
at a greater rate since the start of
nasa's revolution
the concept of a new city as a solution
for cairo's growing population began in
the 1950s the first attempt was under
president kamal abdel nasser who ordered
the construction of a new city called
nasser city
it was also designed to be a new capital
at the time there would be space for
government buildings markets and a huge
new stadium but there was a big flaw the
plan didn't involve affordable housing
for the people in cairo's most crowded
areas
the need was for a lot of lower class
housing
but that wasn't going to be placed in
the new capital right like nobody wants
to build a shiny new capital and then
fill it with low-cost housing so it's
kind of a trend that already starts
there
by the 1970s egypt had a new leader
onward sadat who didn't end up moving
the capital to nasser city
but he really leaned into the trend of
building desert cities
starting in 1976 egypt's government
built eight new cities in the desert
around cairo
each time they claimed the goal was to
alleviate overcrowding
but most included only expensive housing
and barely any featured public
transportation making them inaccessible
for anyone without a car that's why
today many of these desert cities are
only partially occupied most who have
moved here are cairo's middle and upper
class residents that means that the
majority of the population that squeezed
in the little green belt that's now
urbanized around an island are kind of
pets out of these developments
so we're looking at a condition that's a
result of i would say three to four
decades in particular of misguided
policy that looks to the outside of the
city president sisi is continuing that
trend with his new capital these areas
are designed for housing but mostly for
middle and upper class residents
those people are not moving in with
handouts they're buying
their those properties and so the main
target audience is again a money class i
think the housing for low-income
communities will be included in the
capital but definitely very limited
all of this land will be used for
government buildings and this section
will be a business district featuring
this soon-to-be tallest building in
africa so if this new capital isn't
really about solving cairo's population
density crisis
why is the government so determined to
build it
[Music]
in 2011 protests erupted in egypt over
police brutality
and they quickly evolved into widespread
calls for the resignation of egypt's
ruler of 30 years husni mubarak
demonstrations took place all over egypt
but the biggest were in cairo
specifically tahrir square
it's been the epicenter of many
political demonstrations since the early
20th century
largely because it's so close to
egyptian government buildings including
the parliament
in 2011 millions of people occupied
tahrir square for 18 days they set up
roadblocks and battled with police
on february 11th thousands marched from
tahrir square to the presidential palace
10 kilometers away where they ultimately
forced mubarak to step down
the ability to control tahrir square and
inner cairo allowed the protesters to
effectively paralyze the government
making their presence and their demands
impossible to ignore
ccu remembers that
he was the head of egypt's powerful
military when he sees power in 2013 on
the heels of the revolution
barely a month after taking power he
commanded his soldiers and police to
crack down on protesters who opposed him
the brutal raid killed more than 800
people ever since he's been
systematically trying to prevent a
revolution that could topple him his
government has shut down political
dissents punished journalists and
hindered free speech
now they're redesigning several aspects
of cairo to make the city harder to
protest in
they've widened dozens of streets
making it more difficult to erect
roadblocks and they plan to add 40
bridges which will give the military and
police easier access to the city center
cc's government also renovated tavrir
square adding giant monuments and
private security guards which some
experts say will make it harder for
large crowds to gather
now they're taking the final step
removing the government entirely from
cairo
just seven years after announcing the
construction of the new capital
government officials are starting to
move into these new buildings
once that's complete all of egypt's
political power including cc will be
concentrated here almost 50 kilometers
from cairo
and it will all be under heavy guard
this is the military sprawling complex
nearby
even though there's a public square
called the people's piazza it's hard to
imagine millions of people making the
journey from cairo to demonstrate here
and that may be the point
this distance plus the military presence
will allow cece to defend his power in
case of an uprising
so instead of a capital that offers a
solution for the people of cairo
this city is designed to move the
government out of their reach
[Music]
you